again the climate change guys want to
tell us what we can eat what we can't
eat they want to have our phone have
some app that tells them we've used up
our carbon allocation for the year or
for the month and you can no longer buy
steak because you've used too much
carbon it just it just these are people
they've there polls that say that
something like 60% of college kids
nowadays are basically socialists they
have no understanding of what socialism
is done throughout history not not a
shred of an understanding of how not
only is it not work but it kills people
by the countless numbers now capitalism
has bad days but usually that's when
capitalism is turning into socialism
right or fascism actually so when
capitalism goes bad it turns into
fascism because they commment into the
Machinery of government and then they go
destroy the
[Laughter]
hodlers all right guys bang bang I have
Mr Dave column back again uh it's going
to be a spicy conversation as I think
we've had multiple times um but Dave I
thought the first place that we could
start with your year in review is on the
financial markets uh you've got all the
weird stuff you got the conspiracy
theories you got all the craziness in
there just like every other year um but
the financial markets really I think
tell a story that weaves many of these
other things in there together and what
a lot of people may not know about you
is you had this epic investing run up
until about 2009 and then you started to
change your mind about how financial
markets worked about assets that maybe
you wanted exposure to or didn't want
exposure to help us understand over
couple of decades like how has your
thought process about investing
especially the macro Market changed and
then how is that being expressed today
in the
portfolio so so I actually should
preface this with one of the most
cutting emails I got after publishing
this thing I get a lot of support uh
from a a good friend who's a who's a
famous money manager in in Europe and
and he said I I think you've lost your
Edge in investing and I think it's
because you're focusing on all that
other crap and I what I think has
backwards is two things one is that I'm
hunkered down for the
apocalypse and so if I can get a 6%
return then I can that a huge win
because I'll take six% all day for the
time being um where where what I do will
either work or not is when we do have
the next serious downturn which I think
is going to be a Whopper and how I do
during that right that'll that'll deter
whether I've been smart or stupid um but
but but he also has it backwards in the
sense that I'm sitting on my hands like
crazy right so I've got my position and
now I'm just waiting for the markets to
to you know game day to start and and
and so what do I do well I focus on the
other crap and and that's the way it's
what else am I going to read I can read
all the overvaluation crap I want and
it's not going to change my mind at this
point I'm just waiting for
the recession and the the serious
selloff and what I think will be
exceedingly painful period um so in any
man so by way of investing I started out
100% bonds 1980 and there's people say
well it would have been nice to be in
equities well at bonds had about a 12 to
15% return for that decade so it it by
no means was a bad move um 87 crash I
was chatting with a senior colleague in
the C room and and we were talking about
it and he said you know and I knew
nothing about investing when I was a kid
I thought I wanted to go to Wall Street
but I I'd La since not paid attention
and he said you own equities and and I
sort of looked at I said you know you're
right so post 87 crash I moved heavily
into equities and I was a raging Tech
pull which which is incomprehensible to
the people who know me now
incomprehensible and I was buying you
know I didn't buy dos I looked at eBay
um did some math and said said no it's
overvalued too much um and uh but I own
Dell and I own Worldcom I got I got into
Worldcom when it was a tiny little
company in in in Mississippi and I got
out in 99 just so so that was quite a
feat that was uh that turned out to be
just sort of raw luck It Was Fear of the
markets so in any EV so I became a techb
probably in early 90s and I really
believed I mean I was really Kool-Aid
swelling rocking and rolling and and
then it was n so crazy either um and
then it got crazy and in mid 98 I had
studied the structures of markets enough
and I moved half my equities out I just
I just went to Safe Haven and said
there's just something wrong here and uh
and then almost to the day we sort of
marched our way into the Asian crisis
and I said you know you're either a
genius or an idiot I'm not sure which
because you left half exposed and you
got half out of Farm's way and I swore
I'd get the rest out if it came back and
it came back so by mid 99 I was selling
my Dell and Warner Lambert and and
Worldcom and and and and rational
software and all all these companies BMC
Software um my old roommate in college
was Goldman's um software he started
their software group gu Nam Rick
sherlin and uh so I was getting some
pretty good information out of him and
and then I just I I I emptied my my
portfolio completely out of equities by
mid 99 and the NASDAQ was rocking making
me look like an and uh and I I
went into gold I went into gold cash and
I actually went into the prudent Fair
short fund which I've done twice and
done well twice I will never do it again
because I'm just I shouldn't be shorting
it's just it's that's a Fool's game but
um so I I was buying gold from 290 down
to 270 and then I couldn't take any more
pain um but I was I had a standing offer
at the local coin shop said look you get
a couple ounces of gold I'll pay you
cash for it for about the next um I
don't know seven years up to about uh
457 an ounce I I bought gold and funny
story at one point he said to me it was
actually at 457 an ounce and he said he
said don't you think this is the top he
knows I'm G to buy it so he doesn't care
I said no um how many guys are buying
gold from you and he said four total and
I said then the other three are friends
of mine right he said yeah I said I sent
them to you didn't I and he said yeah
and I said that sound like a Mania to
you and he said no and uh so in any case
and then I so I so I carried the gold
all the way up to 1900 in in the early
2000s the best analysis I ever did is I
bought Philip Morris I did the analysis
was right so yeah the fact I made 700%
on Worldcom does I'm not proud of it
because I didn't know what I was doing
but but the Philip Morris I knew what I
was doing I I really did it right so I
did well by that and the various tobacco
stocks and then I also went into energy
I I tried to go into Commodities I
talked to Jimmy Rogers partner for about
two hours I talked to a market maker in
the Rogers Commodity fund it was too
sketchy for me I don't like sketchy and
and and it would have been fine um so I
just went into Fidelity commodity equity
I just started buying you know the the
funds ah Hadad all the big cap oils and
stuff and so um it's all although I
actually had years in a ye at least one
year in the 90s where I made
100% plus
return and that's the that's the
exposure to the market and this is where
it's crazy this shows you it was a Mania
I was 150%
exposed and so I made like 150 % and so
so I um but my best decade was was the
the
2000s and it was not the best decade in
terms of absolute numbers but while
while Equity investors were getting
ravaged by a couple of serious bare
markets um I compounded 133% a year
through from January 1st to 2000 to
January to December 31st to
2009 and that kind of got me on a bit of
a map people sort of I I wrote about it
and people noticed it said oh wow that's
different um and then I wrote about the
subprime crisis on May 6
2002 now I wasn't seeing this I don't do
spreadsheets I was just picking up from
guys like Bill gross and Josh Rosner and
guys saying look we we got a we got a
subprime crisis Brewing here there
they're really you know General
Electrics going way out on the risk
curve this is nuts and and you know the
the the the the the fanny man Freddy
Mack were looking sketchy and I wrote
about in
2002 um I told my
class I I occasionally blurt out to
the class for no reason and in March of
2007 I I turned to the class I said the
banking system's about to
collapse and the indicator was two
things one is the market ABX index was
dropping that was the derivatives market
and no mainstream press wasn't watching
it but the bloggers were saying wait a
minute this thing's just going down down
down what's going on in there and
there's I don't know if you know this
woman Tanta a woman named Tanta she was
blogging on it her name was Doris dunie
and the old veterans will know this uh
she was Seeking Alpha or something and
um and she was talking about she says
you don't understand the chaos
underneath the surface in the pipes of
the system what's happening and that's
when you know they were selling squares
and cubes and stuff and and you know
cpdo it was just crazy time and so um I
would have I did have a prudent bear
short for that for that downturn but but
I would have been Boulder but I didn't
trust counterparty at that point because
I was really a doom and Gomer at that
point and so um so what amazed me is it
really took two more years after I could
hear the market
crack and this is what people don't
understand they they hear this cracking
noise and that's the market breaking and
they think well okay but nothing happen
so we're fine I go no that's the first
of many many noises that you're going to
hear over the next few years and
U so I was confident I was so liquid and
at the bottom I bought some more tobacco
but not much of anything because I was
convinced there was another factor of
two in the downturn and and because we
had done so much damage and what what I
didn't see coming and the best I can
tell no one on the planet saw coming was
$30
trillion right so there's people said oh
I saw it I said they do anything they
have I go show me your blog where you
said 30 trillion because I remember when
they bailed out you know the bare Sterns
for 30 billion and it sucked the auction
out of the room like Oly moly what just
happen Wow that's scary and that's just
chump change right that's just a bad day
in some Regional Bank now um and uh and
and I just and and I'm not and and and
of course you'll hang out of the gold
because because because if they're going
to dump 30 trillion but but something
somehow the inflation didn't catch and
it's because they were basically shoving
it into the Federal Reserve as reserves
and so it wasn't getting into the paws
of the people and so it wasn't going
direct as they say um so I really miss
the inflation thing I thought inflation
should have gone wild um and uh so I was
basically Liquid Gold you know I I had
the the the energy till about 16 which I
overstayed my welcome there uh started
going back in 20 um thanks to Jesse
Felder and thanks to kicking Exxon out
of the da I said you kick Exxon out of
the da replace with salesforce.com I'm
buying Exxon that that's real
straightforward and um but not a big POS
big enough that I care but not big
enough to to really to really you know
it's not lifechanging and um and um and
so I've been you know sort of
compounding four or five% a year for
through a decade where everyone else is
partying like crazy and so so I've got
people saying you know you're such an
idiot you know when are you going to
admit you're
wrong but but there's one metric on Wall
Street that that is never going to be
broken and that is that that that the
valuations of the market will mean
regress
and and the markets are yes absolutely
yes I do now so um one of the ideas that
I see circulating online and I I don't
know yet
uh all of the Nuance surrounding it but
but I think the main idea is QE and what
they did in 2009 broke the market and
now you have this world where uh anytime
there are going to be these Market draw
Downs they rush in they're going to you
know kind of Outlaw bare markets Outlaw
recessions um
and because of that the historical
valuation
metrics are harder to use to evaluate
today what is overvalued and what is not
overvalued so how do you kind of balance
the the macro environment may have
changed the tools they use may have
changed when you're using those
valuation
metrics um well so so to make the
assumption that the valuations are never
coming down means that you will own
invest vestments let's say we're 150%
overvalued so you're making so the
markets are priced to make 40% of what
you would if the market was were priced
at fair value so
um there's a plot in my year review I've
got an even better one that Ron GCE sent
to me um that shows the S&P over the
last 100 years corrected for M2 money
supply which is a far cleaner inflation
metric than and I don't think he's
published that that's the funny thing I
think he just sent that to me I'm I'm
not sure and I don't know if I've never
seen I've been watching for it I've
never seen anyone else publish it but
but what it shows is is is that if you
correct the markets for M2 money supply
which seems like a stunningly clean way
to correct for inflation um over the
last 100 years the markets have drifted
downward slightly now so the conclusion
that I drew from that is that is that
all you got were
dividends so now back at the 100 years
ago markets were returning 6 and a half%
yield dividends and now they're
returning 1 and a half% so so that so so
if you want to say the markets are going
to stay up at this price you have to say
and therefore I'm GNA get a return of
about a third of what I would have
normally gotten now he sent me a
modified version of the plot which he
did the total
return and the total return turns out to
be over 100 years
3.79% that is the dividends right so
that's it so so my claim that it's all
dividends that's what the average
dividend was over that period now the
interesting thing is that um that that
Buffett in his fith iconic 1999 Fortune
article said that the after you're all
done and by the way his his uh Grace's
plot does not include taxes and fees and
it's just the market index so you
take a a 3.79% return over 100 years and
start pulling that other out of
there you're hurt I mean you're really
hurt um Buffett said the most you can
ever hope to get by the time you're done
unwinding everything but he didn't
include
taxes was 4 per. now ever says oh Warr
Buffett knows everything but then they
ignore that 4 perc part and um and so
that's about right that's what Grace's
plat shows and um and and that's what
Ben Grant said years ago and Ben Graham
said look stocks and bonds are going to
return the same over a long period
period um Ed mcquary followed up on that
same thing so people have an expectation
which as you know since you suffered
your way through this damn thing um as
you know for the last 40 years the
markets have been on a Roid Rage so so
the recency bias is not from 2000 it's
not from it's not from 2008 or n it's
not from it's not from 2000
it's not from it's it's not from 1987
it's from
1981 and it turns out the most stunning
statistic from 1981 is that the market
valuations this is getting to your point
the market valuations not the which are
inherently inflation corrected because
it's the price divided by something that
attract like GDP or sales or revenues or
Tobin Q or whatever um Cas Schiller um
it it turns out that they compounded a
little over 3% a year for 40 goddamn
years that means you had a three three
point something percent Tailwind from
the low of 81 where he couldn't give
that away to the high where people
would buy any piece of that that
moved um so so so then the question I
asked rhetorically is what happens over
the next 40 years when that 3% turns
into a negative
3% and it will
I just don't know when but it will I
mean there there's a there's a there's a
sort of a if you go back to you know
Ancient Rome or something you'll find
there's a there's a margin of return
that's
modest but it's above inflation you know
that's what you demand you're you're not
going to ask for inflation payment
you're going to ask for something a
little above and and um and if if your
price to get almost nothing then you'll
get almost
nothing so you essentially in the letter
say that you divorced equities in 99 and
you married gold in cash right um when
you look at that uh there's a whole new
generation of people who actually agree
with your thesis and say you know what I
want to hold some cash to spend and I
want to hold uh some sort of asset that
will benefit from this inflation that
has you know sound money principles
right they seem to be going towards
Bitcoin not gold right each time we've
talked you've had a little bit varied
view of Bitcoin how do you think about
it
now well I know an awfully large number
of smart people who are enthusiastic
about
Bitcoin what keeps me away from Bitcoin
people don't understand a couple things
one is I'm a bit of a
lite and
and Bitcoin is a digital
asset and I don't even trust the damn
Cloud right I I don't trust I I I I have
trouble with I've had cloud storage
screw me up and and you know I password
problems and stuff like that so so I I
find and at one point I couldn't get
stuff out of box I put a bunch of
important stuff box I couldn't get it
out and they said oh by the way you're
over your limit now you got to pay for
more storage I'm going to get my
out are you kidding me and and so um so
Bitcoin I I know I can hear all the
Bitcoin guys going oh but they can't
touch us I
go I kind of don't first first and
foremost I don't need the half of heav
the world about the tech behind Bitcoin
now I think if I spent huge amount of
time reading about it I would come to
terms with it but um it's still a
digital asset to me it's still something
that I could imagine somehow when they
finally suck me if if I go into Bitcoin
one could argue that's when you guys
should
sell right um and every hler out there
seems to want me to go into Bitcoin I'm
like the hold out or something I don't
know what it is but boy they all go at
me and and they're civil
I I I I think the hodlers are you know I
think they understand that I'm
sympathetic um the second thing is is I
am confident that at some point you guys
are either going to be absorbed by the
state or do battle with the state and
that's a capital S State that's not
that's and and and you haven't yet right
that day is in the future sometime and
you know for once in a while you hear a
yelling or you know Christine lagard or
someone say something that's sort of a
shot across your bow and you guys flipp
her off and you
know but but at some point I think
you're gonna have to do battle with the
S I think it's going to be epic it's
going to be Battle of the bastards I
call it and and
and you guys are GNA win or
lose I'm not
interested in participating in that
battle right now it hasn't caught my
attention now Lyn Alden made one of the
more interesting cases she kind of
presented as the the equivalent of
stitching diamonds in the Hem of your
clothes escaping some totalitarian
regime and you have your codes right you
have your codes and that I'm more
sympathetic to
except I'm too old to be running from
you know I'm the old guy sitting in the
middle of kab going you I'm not
moving right so so uh one of your big
themes is that the
totalitarianism is increasing all around
us and to a degree it's already here
right especially in this kind of digital
um o overlords so it's surprising to me
that I know you are sympathetic but also
you don't want to buy it well so the
other problem is is I I wouldn't go
there's there's it'd be very hard for me
to picture going in deeply enough to be
lifechanging so is I you know I did this
great analysis of moris I made a lot of
money over the years it's not
lifechanging if all those I I I bet on I
bet on Russia as the RSX
index two days before I had owned it for
several years I wasn't alone Grant
Williams was interested in it too and
copying these
guys but two days before it went South I
said I'm taking a flyer on it and I
bought it and then it went to zero right
it might come back I don't think so I I
think by the time it comes back JP
Morgan will find a way to steal my
RSX but um but but at the same time
there's no way I would have gone deep
enough into it to really make a killing
because I don't I don't do it that way I
average in over time so I could average
into Bitcoin over time um people say
what price would interest you it's not
about price it's it's it's about it's
about the the the battle with the state
and the annoyance of having to worry
about my codes and it just it's
just not it's not interesting to me I'm
I'm I'm sort of G to hang with gold and
I have physical gold and and so it's I'm
you know Bitcoin light by that model I'm
I'm a
godler um so let's talk about some of
the uh topics that you covered okay um
and there's a there's a third there's a
third one that I haven't completed
writing on which is the darkness it's
total dark lord go ahead saw that
in January 2024 the third part will come
out so if if I can finish writing it
it's so painful to write I don't know
but go ahead all right uh digital
totalitarianism uh you have a section uh
you say we are already being ruled by
algorithms and our future is offering up
authoritarian cbdcs digital IDs facial
recognition software and carbon budgets
all enabled with AI it is a March
towards digital
authoritarianism is there any way to
stop it or is this just like a for
conclusion
I don't think so so so that the the
Troublesome thing is is that
um is it the basil level not even humans
trying to get us sort of level but just
the creep of of every time you use your
credit card or every time you go through
security at the airport or whatever
you're you're you're handing an a
decision over to an algo and it's going
to say yes or no it's always binary yes
let them through no kill them you know
whatever and and every time you put in
your credit card it says yes you you get
to buy that item or no you don't and and
and I gotta confess I'm annoyed when I
have to go find my phone to log into
some website because it they want to do
the double double password and and
I go you know I this site's not that
important to ask me to do that I my bank
account's fine but this site's not
worthy and so so
um we are going to increasingly ask um
computers to make decisions for us so my
wife has health problems as you know and
and I have to go through all these
Health portals and and I'm reading my
own lab reports and and I I made a
joke I thought was funnier than
about how you're going to do your next
colonoscopy using a a robotic Geral
fitted with a GoPro camera that you run
off your iPhone um but Medical care is
getting like that and and so we're
really we're every time you hand over
the one time I got I was on a a help
call I was talking to a helpl line and
and I'm really sympathetic to what it's
like to be on the end of one of those
right because everyone's always pissed
off about something and I lost my
because I kep saying look I don't
understand this word that you're using
and then I got off the
phone after having lost my and I
thought were you talking to a
computer because it felt like it was
circling
around and and I realized I said you're
you're talking to AI
computer and and I I don't want to talk
to an AI computer I don't want to read a
Blog not knowing if it's written by AI
or a person right I don't want to read
AI blogs I think there are times where
an AI write up on something would be
instructive but we can end up in a point
where everything online is just Ai and
by the way it turns into gibberish fast
when it's just AI someone mentioned that
recently where they said when AI is
feeding off of AI it spirals out of
control real fast now they might fix
that but that's I'm right now reading
Michael malice's book called the white
pill it's it's a stunningly good book
it's about the Soviet Union and how
awful it was and and you're left with
this do not let that happen here it's so
so here here's the the short
story of of this book just to get your
attention we know that Stalin killed 40
million what no one knows or very very
few people know is
how what transpired while 40 million
people were getting killed he didn't
just Li them up and shoot him in
ditches it was Society completely
imploded on itself and and it just
turned it just it just went completely
toxic and and somehow was created by
first Lon and then Stalin but but but
but the the message is very clear to me
don't let that happen here and you can
see it happening here now we're miles
and miles from that maybe the US and the
Western World doesn't have the Russian
DNA like cultural DNA to ever go
there but it's possible and I I'm I'm in
infuriated with the current
Administration who seems to have no
respect for the Constitution
and and you can say oh he's just a
right- Winger you know no no no I would
be appalled I you know I didn't support
I I I went totally negative on George
Bush when he got us into Iraq you know
no I'm not just a right-winger but but
this Administration is is is is totally
throwing the basic principles of who we
are under the bus what are some examples
uh the Border let's start with the
border so they're just letting people
flood through the Border I I'm not
against immigration yeah yeah let's
unpack this because I think that um
there's a big portion of the audience
that uh they understand kind of what's
happening right they see the videos
online Etc why do you think it's
happening do you think it is uh a
conspiracy that you know they've come
together and they said hey we should do
this because you know I've seen theories
that uh it'll increase the number of
people who vote Democrat all the way to
uh The Other Extreme which is like no
this is a complex problem people are
inom
and therefore rather than try to come up
with a solution they just say screw it
let whatever happen happens and that
leads to you know hundreds of thousands
of people come across the border every
year like which that I that one I that
one I don't believe okay I I don't even
I don't even see a token effort right
now if you listen to that that liar
press conference uh press secretary
Karen what's her name um she's out
claiming right from day one they try to
get control of the Border there's not a
shred of evidence not a shred so so no
they they welcomed everyone they could
shut off the Border they could have done
it they fought Trump the whole way when
he tried to do it um and so
uh there's there's a benign
interpretation one benign interpretation
is that someone's watching Peter Zan and
saying we need more people and Zan is
you know this demographer who's a a
neocon of a higher order but he's a
demographer and he says look our I we're
at 1.6 you know population replacement
which means we're going to have trouble
we're going to have a terrible time but
not as bad as other countries but we're
going to have a terrible time and so so
one could argue that someone has a
twisted view of how to solve that
problem that's the most benign um it
looks to me like it's an attempt to
destroy the concept of a border so it's
it looks to me like it's a globalist
move and and and if you know there's two
nationalists in the world who are really
devout nationalists that that that you
can name there's more um but but but
there's two really stand out and the two
are are are Trump and
Putin and and and who's getting the most
GFF right Trump and Putin and and so I
would say that um I would say that um
that the United States stands between
the globalists the guys who really do
want to have a borderless world for some
reason that I don't quite understand
except for power um Power is everyone
seems to want um and so you destroy the
borders right and you get you know I
used to laugh off the Soros arguments
but then he starts you know he's been
helping Place Das and stuff and you know
the January 6 to me was one of the most
heinous periods Post January 6 was one
most heinous periods of of American
history that that we've locked people
away for years for having gone to a
protest and I can hear people screaming
going no no they did this they did that
no they didn't those were fed in the
crowd the the the the crowd nothing was
going to happen without the feds
intervening at January 6 nothing bad
nothing really bad was going to happen
and and then you know there's 40,000
hours of tape and they won't they still
won't release it but whenever they do
you go holy that guy didn't do
anything and he got how many years in
prison right so I don't know if you know
who this person is um Felix somari
there's know the Raven of Zurich this
took me months to track down um and for
those that don't know uh he was very
well respected in he was able to call a
number of Market tops bottoms throughout
the world wars and um uh became you know
somewhat of a trusted Confidant of many
Bankers economists Etc and in the book
he has this uh story when he was a young
kid I think he's like 12 13 years old uh
there's a Shoemaker that he's talking
with and the Shoemaker uh has an accent
and he's you know a 12-year-old
right he starts making fun of the of the
guy's accent and his dad basically slaps
him and says you know hey we don't do
that here and in the book he claims that
from then on he was immune I think the
exact quote is I was immune to the virus
of any
nationalism right and so I think
nationalism doesn't require
though we have States right yes I don't
sit there and look at the guys in
Pennsylvania say oh the
Pennsylvania
douchebags it's just a way of organizing
soci Society so break down the
difference between what I think some
people see as like uh nationalism driven
by hate and a zero sum game versus kind
of more the organizational things the
the pride of being from a nation the you
know what I would consider much more
innocent view of the importance of
nationalism not so much a zero sum game
but maybe actually a positive sum game
this episode is brought to you by aradon
they are a brand new startup led by a
number of Silicon Valley Legends who
just raised $81 million to build the
future of Internet infrastructure you're
probably wondering what that means let
me explain there are numerous new
disruptive technologies that are being
adopted simultaneously from blockchain
to artificial intelligence to zero
knowledge Technologies in order to
ensure that these Technologies thrive in
this new world we need new
infrastructure and that is where arine
comes in they just launched their first
product line called Tera flux which is a
Bitcoin miner powered by the world's
first 4 nanometer silicon chip
technology these air cooled singlephase
and dual phase emerging cooling miners
have unrivaled speed and efficiency
they've Superior uptime and they
leverage a brand new innovation called
Energy tune that allows miners to
dynamically adjust the energy
consumption and Bitcoin hash rate based
on demand response needs of the
electrical grids aradine is an ambitious
company working on hard problems I'm
really impressed with them and if you
want to check out more you can go to
rodine.isfeld I ne.com go check them out
at idine.com today well so so if you
I've I've read a lot of anthropology for
example I I love history um as Society
got bigger right we went from you know a
dozen guys running through some jungle
in Borneo to uh across the Savannah to
to bigger groups like 150 you start
picking up structurally different
societies by by necessity right so the
pure anarchists just don't get it you
you have to somehow start building
structure and I think there's kind of a
natural evolution of structure and so at
this point the the the the the na the
the the nation state is kind of the
natural um structure for the current
world now the globalists might say yes
but we're heading away from the current
world and therefore we should go to a
globalist world but it's also a world
that they want to run
and that's you know it's like it's I
have a quote in there where someone says
you know you know you know follow people
who are trying to find the truth you
know be wary of those who actually think
they found it um and so um so the nation
states still to me make
sense and and and um I I don't want some
guy in Brussels telling us to not eat
meat for example which is the stupid
stuff that're already pushing right
so all already the the globalist view of
the world is looking so
stupid stupid evil some combination of
the two that I don't want anything to do
with it it just doesn't make sense I
actually think in some sense one of the
reasons why I'm a pro-choice guy but
roie way in some sense makes
sense because I don't see there why
there's why why Mississippi should
necessarily have to follow the same
moral values is
California they're really different
populations in a profound sort of way
and and I know that R8 happens to be a
highly charged issue but there there's
still little sort of states rights
mentality in me and I don't think we
should I think there's a lot of things
that should be at the state level
um but but I see things happening on a
daily basis that
um that seems so evil to me like now
there's two states that have tried to
keep Trump off the
ballot the woman in Maine I did a tweet
the other day that got a lot of support
um I said should she be tried for um um
for um depriving both us and Trump of
our civil
rights you know there are crimes in
which you deprive someone of their civil
rights that's how they convict some
people and stuff and I said if she takes
him off the bout that's depriving me of
my civil rights and so I think she
should be convicted if if if if it turns
out the story that we're being told is
correct right they always comes back to
that for all we know it's a fake story
for Christ's sakes I know a robot wrote
the damn thing um and but but but the it
was truly unbelievable to me that the
Colorado Supreme Court for example could
take him off the ballot these are these
are supposed to be super
learned judicial people and I think a
five-year-old could explain to them
why they made a mistake I mean I think I
can explain it I used to go home from
faculty means and talk to my you know
son who was like seven say Thomas here's
the setup boom boom boom what do you do
and he'd say here's what you do and I go
yeah my colleagues don't seem to see
that part you know um and so so the fact
they took him off a ballot is to me
truly
extraordinary and and it's and then you
have to say but it it can't even be for
the reason that it appears to be right
it's it's
not there's something else altoe they're
try if it was a republican Court I'd say
whe they're trying to generate support
for the guy because it sure as hell I'm
I'm voting for Trump period I want to
see him get in there and go Green Goblin
on him I I I've just lost my at
this point I I don't I want him to get
in there and cause trouble there's
context here that I think if people
haven't read the year in rview they need
to understand in 2016 I think you say
you begrudgingly voted for him or were
cous cautiously um and then in 2020 you
were kind of agnostic explain a little
bit as to why were you cautious or you
know kind of reluctant in 2016 why
agnostic in 2020 and now I hear both in
the letter but also uh from you it
sounds like a much more kind of hardened
heels dug in un voting for him what is
that Evolution like well so the first
evolution was I I had been aware of
trump the developer Trump The Narcissist
Trump the so in
16 um in 16 when he ran I said this
guy's just Looney Tunes right now I
actually had read um an article written
in 1984 about him as a developer it was
really interesting because everyone
found him Beyond annoying but he always
got the deal he always got they say you
know everyone wanted that piece of real
estate somehow Donald got it and I can't
understand how he did it and people
would say you know after a while you
just say Donald just tell me what you
want just just and that's how he works
right and and I I watched the
documentary recently and they he built a
huge office complex one time and he
didn't get any of the signatures wife G
oh that's so criminal and I go that's
hutzpah I that's that no that's that's
not just criminal that's a guy who who
really and and the the concrete workers
were on strike but his his his building
was getting concrete
he go that's because he's in with a mob
he's such a bad person I go he's getting
the job done right and so there's always
two that those sort of two sides to
Trump and um and I watch them knock off
13 Republican candidates I'm going boy
that was impressive the way he did that
even though someone referred to it as
incompetent and I go he just knocked off
13 people right now he's going against
Hillary right no one else could have
done that that's not incompetent it's
extra
orinary so uh I could have voted for
Bernie over
Trump because I thought ah he's generic
they'll neuter him he can't do any
damage although I'm not positive that's
true so Trump gets an office you'd be
hardpressed to name something he did
that was really bad you really would be
hard pressed you can oh he's a liar I go
oh no one ever lies in DC right Trump's
a artist Biden's a liar they're
different Trump will say I caught a fish
this damn big and and Biden will say I
graduated from this college first my
class and he didn't graduate from that
Co college right one's a lie one's
um and so I I had no trouble
voting for him in 2020 but I wasn't sure
I wanted more the chaos I was thinking
if they Dems could come up with a
candidate and bring us back to Earth a
little bit that would be okay with me
and then watching what they've done to
him over the next four years I go okay
let's elect him he knows where the
spoons and forks are he know he know
when he first got into office he
couldn't build a cabinet he couldn't he
didn't know who to trust he he couldn't
trust anyone from either party neither
party wanted him in there he now has his
war war um cabinet and I want to see him
do it now it could get
ugly but it's not his fault not in my
opinion so I heard uh stories through
the rumor mill of people who either
worked in the administration or uh know
Trump that when he first got into office
uh there would be situations where you
know he's sleeping at night and he would
get a phone call and so the staff member
would come in and say you know excuse me
president I'm sorry to wake you up but
uh there's a general on the line in Iraq
Afghanistan wherever and basically they
were calling and they needed the
president's approval for you know a
strike very similar to Obama having to
give the final order to go after Osama
Bin Laden and things like this and
supposedly Trump would be like was he a
bad guy
right okay we'll kill him right the
Simplicity of it I mean there's there's
and he's not stupid if you watch his
documentary you watch the things he did
people think well you know he's totally
un uncontrolled he went to Military
Academy he was a leader at the military
academy I mean he's not he's not the
he's not the loser he appears to be he's
idiosyncratic that's a that's different
and so um and you would be hard pressed
to you know so the for me one of the
drop dead issues that allowed me to vote
for him the first time was he said we
have to get along with the
Russians and I said he's dead
right and then of course they hang
Russia collusion all over him and they
got nothing they got you know the the
the the the the Durham report gave a
little bit to everyone but when you got
to the bottom line he explicitly says we
found no collusion period none
and and the I think it's treasonous to
make the up the way the Democrats
do I I I think that if you really I
don't know what the formal definition of
treason is but in my skull I have a
definition of treason and when when
you're to me it's a it's pretty close to
a couet when you're doing the they
did against them and and and it looks to
me to me the B Administration itself
looks like a cou d' in it in in the
reverse sense I mean they're doing
like when B was told by the Supreme
Court you couldn't cancel student loans
he just tried to find another way to do
it I what do you do when the president
ignores the Supreme Court they can't
just have to rule on him every
day at some point they got to be able to
say no no Joe Brandon whatever your name
is stop and and I don't care how many
right-wing Supreme Court there are
that's sort of the bottom line for me
and so um and and so I I I think the B
Administration has been truly horrific
and I think the January 6 um sty and
Lenin show trial component of January 6
um it's a horrific chapter in history
horrific chapter in history and I I have
friends who say you know you do the time
the crime you do the time right and I go
well first of all show me the crime
second of all you know how I defend a
January 6 person it turns out your brain
chemistry changes in a
mob temporary insanity you could get
psychologists who say yeah yes temporary
insanity place but there wasn't
done it was feds in the goddamn crowd
doing the and and so I I see things
that are
so so non to toille so so anti to
everything everything that that the sort
of fundamental principles that we used
to think we stood for maybe I was just
dead wrong um there was some bad at
the turn of the century in the United
States that was happening some really
non constitutional
things um and so so that's that's what's
got me angry and and the problem is is
it's it's not making me happier and it's
it's also I don't see where it's getting
me closer to some sort of
solution so that's the problem let me
ask one last question on politics and
we'll go on some of the other topics um
it sounds like uh you believe Trump will
win yes or no oh I don't know no I think
they'll Rigg the
election okay they did they did the
first time 2020 was
rigged 2020 was rigged it explain your
logic for uh for having so much
confidence in that now well first and
foremost I think there's plenty of
evidence second of all most importantly
the one that I go look look at both
parties by the way no one wanted them in
the White House correct neither party
wanted him in the White
House they did everything imaginable to
impeachments indictments you name it to
keep them out of the White House is
there any chance they said oh but we
can't rig the
election you want to bet on that
one no it's insane to bet on that one of
course they rigged the election they've
been rigging it for years but it's kind
of a capture of the flag rig where it's
you know you know dinking around over
here a they stole Pennsylvania from us
you know like that this was a whale
rigging under the guise of the co
lockdown and the mail and ballots and
all that and Carrie lake has a
great case for the rigged election and
if you you dig into the smartmatic
voting machines it turns out through a
series of shell companies they trace to
Beijing I mean it it's just it's a it's
a colossal mess and and the problem is
there's there's no evidence they're
going to ever run a clean election
they'll run a clean election when they
don't care which side wins then let it
be clean but we know we all hate these
guys right we know we'd vote every last
one of them out of
office but they have a 97% reelection
rate that's not
rigging that just shows you the
hopelessness the Democrats superdelegate
model is an Abomination right they the
fact that 30% of the goddamn delegates
come from
insiders who get to just vote however
they're told to vote that's just a
staggering
but but it turns out that if you look at
the structure of political parties
they're just non for-profit
organizations the only way you'd stop
the Democrats from doing what they do
and the rep Republicans from doing what
they do I think if you let's say you
want to stop it I think you'd have to
charge him with some sort of RICO charge
and say you fundraised under false under
pretenses pretenses means fals ATT turns
I just kind of realized that under
pretenses you you you you committed
fraud by raising money the way you did
that's that's how I would go at them if
I if if now on the other hand who wrote
the book God damn it I can never
remember the name someone wrote a book
about the
legality underlying the the the the
court actions underlying the uh 2008 to9
crisis and they talked about all the
cases that that they built against Wall
Street guys in some some appeals court
would spend three hours looking at the
date and throw it out after they' spent
months building a case against so no one
went to jail right
nobody couple of little guys couple of
couple of Indian guys from the hedge
fund right yeah get the Indian guys why
not we don't care about them um and so
uh and so I just
see criminal treasonous levels of
behavior from A system that I don't
remember showing yeah let's talk about
climate change which is another topic
topic that uh I think you explicitly
said climate change is a scam uh in the
letter explain what uh what you think's
going on
there well I have to go back a few years
I've got an email Trail which I've got
people pestering me about it and I'm
saying look all my friends believe it
the scientific Community believes that I
don't know where you're going with this
right I actually was sitting with a
Secretary of Energy one day and told him
I was agnostic and he flinched I said it
would take me 10,000 hours to figure it
out so I'm not qualified to cast a vote
um my brother and some other guy
pestered me into digging into it and I
finally out of frustration I said to the
other guy name David Walker he I
said as far as I know there's no
credible scientists who don't believe
this story and I have to sort of go with
the science right it pry
fouchy um he said oh yes there are I
said send me names so I expect him to
send me names of people from Shaban
State College of finearts you know and
things like that and that they're not
going to be credible and I they could
know but but if I'm going to overturn a
globally accepted Theory it's going to
take more than some guy from sh Shaban
right and um he sends me about 20 names
of people who were at Elite
institutions so I go okay but there
probably bunch of climate scientists who
said this model sucks or that model
sucks and therefore you know we got to
redo them and and the deniers are
turning that into therefore there's no
climate
change so I start googling them and
that's not what they're saying so you
hit guys like you know right away hit
Richard lindson former head of the NA
national National Academy of Sciences a
geophysicist at MIT says it's the
biggest hoax in history and you
go whoa whoa you find out the American
physics Society put together an elite
panel a dozen guys said you're charged
with looking into this and they all came
out deniers they all said this is just
crap science just total crap science
from that group emerged you know Freeman
Dyson right that guy's one of the
legends of physics will haer I think was
on that committee I'm not positive but
so I can name for you Nobel Prize
winners in
physics um that say that it's totally a
farce so a guy like um um Richard coonan
wrote a book and I think he thought
could have an effect it's not about
science but he was on the committee um
and so he wrote a book and what he does
is he kind of tries to tight RPP walk
where he says you know CL you know man
influences climate butt then he proceeds
to torch it now he's he's internally
inconsistent because he says he says
there's not a snowball's chance in hell
that the scientific Community has the
capabilities of predicting the
temperature 100 years from now and here
the 10,000 reasons why here are
all the things they can't account for
you know physicist at Stanford says the
airbar on their numbers five times the
number you know there that the former
founder Green Piece says this is
complete farce the guy who ran the NASA
satellite program monitoring temperature
said it's a farce you find out that some
of the big climate change guys are
compulsive liars pathological
liars and um and then you start picking
up the little tidbits like you know the
melting Glacier oh Dave look at The
Melting Glacier and you find out that
underneath that Glacier are 1,200 year
old
trees which means they grew there 12200
years
ago and therefore the glacier is not
melting after a million or 10 million or
100 million years it's just going back
and forth oscillating you know I I saw a
headline that said that you know they
hasn't been this warm in 600 years I go
let's rewrite the headline it was this
warm 600 years ago
um and and then you know the you see the
picture of The Starving polar bear if
there's anyone watching this who doesn't
have the image of that starving polar
bear on an ice flow who looks pretty
emaciated and you find out the world's
expert on Arctic mammal says that the
polar bear population has tripled since
the 70s the world's experts on the the
Great Barrier Reef say The Reef
oscillates back and forth and it's s
climate uh the increasing salinity of
the of the uh of the ocean turns out
didn't hold up that got blown out of the
water last year this year's winner the
Nobel Prize in physics said that it's
it's such a first they can't even
account for
clouds clouds you know how important
clouds are and influencing the earth's
climate and the sun's radiation and and
so um what you find is I I got to sit
down with Constantine kaon for about an
hour this this fall he's the guy who
gave the talk at the Oxford Union and if
you haven't watched it you really got to
watch it um and and I said to him I said
when you started digging into climate
change how long did it take you to
figure out that it was a farce and he
said a couple
hours it's that bad actually and so what
you discover is the 97 and Michael kryon
picked out this one the
97% consensus number which they all site
lying their asses off you lying
if you're a climate person
and you cite that number you're a lying
that came from a ridiculous
study of a bunch of
papers where they took several thousand
papers looked in the abstract which I'm
okay with and they threw out all the
papers which the abstract wasn't
definitive and and
said what percentage of the the
abstracts that made a definitive
statement um said was a crisis they said
97% well it turns out it was 77 out of
79 papers out of thousands of papers
that they threw away most CR point out
he say something like 0.4% of the sample
size was used to come up with
97% of the the 97% number so they're
lying pathological lying if you're a
climate scientist you quote that number
you're a liar I'm calling you out you're
a
okay I'm that angry at it and I
called the guy there's a debate here and
I walked up afterwards I said you know
you're lying about that number you cited
it you know you're lying he was Hamming
and ha like crazy and I said you got to
stop doing that so I'm calling out the
serious climate scientists and saying if
you don't clean up this if you don't
clean up this community and if you don't
start challenging we're just gonna
throw you all away you're just gonna end
up on some dust Heap with all the vax
guys who supported
fouchi so yeah so and and by the way
coonan's statement about how man-made
climate change is real but not a problem
and then he proceeds to make the case
you can't possibly predict it he's
contradicting
himself because he should never say
man-made climate change is real if you
can't possibly make the prediction so
then so I saw Thomas Soul talk about it
the other day and he he he points out a
very important one he says that one
alone I'm waiting for an answer I'm not
getting it and that is if you look at
you know 300,000 years of the CO2
content of the ice which you can get out
of Greenland ice course and the
temperature which you can get various
ways um which I believe they know how to
do it that the um there's an 8800e
lag so you take the two curves which
they correlate beautifully visually if
you look at this PL you go look at that
see how2 correlates with the climate
well there's an 800 year offset CO2
Rises 800 years after the temperature
rises and they're trying to say CO2 is
causing the temperature to rise when in
fact no what happens is the temperature
rises the oceans de gas the CO2 comes
out of the ocean and the CO2 content
goes up and they just lie they just
ignore that then they you know the the
Middle Ages so haer I saw a haer
interview the other day and I I I did a
climate change podcast for the guy who's
been following this since' 07 I
said here's the here's the killer
question I said do you know and this guy
I think is honest I said do you know any
solar
physicist who believe the man-made
climate change story says no not a one
he's been doing podcast right about
since ' 07 not a single solar physicist
believes the climate model and so haer
starts talking say they're now changing
all the numbers from the past they're
just going back and rewriting the
numbers and backfilling and so what was
called the medieval warming period when
it was warmer than it is now they're
trying to rewrite those numbers to make
it cooler so he says he says the numbers
from the past are now
changing
when you see so many people convinced or
at least saying publicly one thing but
you're coming to a different
conclusion what is
the information or what is the uh data
that you think could convince people to
see it the other way that are not in the
scientific community or do you think
that this is one of those arguments
where logic is uh logic succumbs to this
like fake morality and people then
believe oh to be a good person I have to
believe this thing regardless of what
the evidence
suggest so it's it's both categories um
I think I think there's sound thinking
people that have simply never
asked and if you threw the data at them
I've given several talks on it no one
has ever come up to me and challenged
anything I
presented um and and um so I think
there's people I could convince you give
me an hour I could convince them I could
just show them after after
that just doesn't make sense you
know scandals which the scientists claim
they admit they lie because they got to
keep the narrative going that sort of
thing um then there's the group that
have you read Eric Hofer is the True
Believer no I have not it's a brilliant
book I know we all get told what books
to read but this is a brilliant book
written in 1953 and it's about mass
movements so it's kind of an early
version of mathas desmet's more recent
book um which is also a good book um and
and the True Believers are are sort of
the standing army the people the the
foot soldiers in in
movements and they they um typically in
these movements you've got early
thinkers the guys who put forth an idea
like uh like in the social justice
the early thinkers were guys like
Herbert marusa and his wife and stuff
like that they put out the idea sort of
in the abstract and then it then you get
the movers and the Shakers and what
happens is the
Army it's not a very flattering view but
the the the the the guys who sort of run
the ball really carry the ball blocking
and tackling um are typically um serious
losers as described by Hofer who have
very little to show for their lives and
he says um he says that what that does
it teas them up for two things one is
that they um that they they say well
anything would be better than what I'm
experiencing that's how you get people
to sign off on socialism and things like
that and and and and by becoming part of
a
movement you become more important you
become the True Believer and you become
you now have a sense of purpose so I I
threw out a few barbs about climate
change to my class and it they landed
like bricks my brother pointed out he
says it's like telling it's like telling
some some Muslim that Muhammad's a
pedophile it just doesn't work it's not
going to work and then I realize yes
because the kids in my grad course now
have been told by every authority figure
since
daycare right to the present that it's a
crisis what it is is it's $150 trillion
grift and everyone who wants a piece of
that pie and when you have a $150
trillion pie there's a lot of people
want a piece of that
pie they'll all sign off on it I got
colleagues you know look my opening
three paragraphs my grand proposed the
doe is about climate change
right they're not going to come out say
look climate change is but I
want
money there are no unfunded climate Den
there are no funded climate
deniers it it's a the darwinian
selection has cleaned the scientific
Community absolutely pristinely out of
all the people who would question it
because they no longer have money they
no longer therefore publish papers they
no longer have a say so we've so they no
longer have a seat at the table which is
exact exactly by the way what they did
with Co and the
vaccine when you see the oil companies
uh getting added to like the ESG index
and Tesla being taken out um is that ju
is that just a signal that even the
people who would not normally be uh
associated with ESG they're really good
at lobbying they're really good at
spending money they're just grifters
they're just grifters that that's Larry
Fink trying to get Vanguard money right
uh the the
ESG or their globalists right you know
again the climate change guys want to
tell us what we can eat what we can't
eat they want to have our phone have
some app that tells we've used up our
carbon allocation for the year or for
the month and you can no longer buy
steak because you've used too much
carbon it's just it's just these are
people they've got there polls that say
that something like 60% of college kids
nowadays are basically
socialists they have no understanding of
what socialism is done throughout
history not not a shred of an
understanding of how not only is it not
worked but it kills people by the
countless numbers now capitalism has bad
days but usually that's when capitalism
is turning into
socialism right or fascism actually so
when capitalism goes bad it turns into
fascism because they commment under the
Machinery of
government and then they go destroy the
[Laughter]
hodlers another topic that you write
about is um biological males competing
in women's sports I haven't written yet
but yes I'm going at it yeah well you at
least mention it in um in the first part
um talk a little bit as to less about
[Music]
um maybe how we got here but where do we
go from here is the for like one of the
the concepts that I'm really interested
in is uh there's a number of things uh
immigration at the border uh whether it
is you know biological males competing
in uh women's sports leagues all these
things they have momentum and to reverse
momentum there's only a couple of ways
to do it right there's some kind of
Awakening I I think you know kind of the
lockdowns were an Awakening for some
people and they literally picked up and
they moved to other states like like
there there's got to be some extreme
external thing that that forces it or
there also can be one or a very small
group of people with the backbone the
Courage the leadership skills the
communication skills Etc to stand up and
you know basically educate folks and say
hey look this is not what I agree with
I'm in a leadership position I'm going
to change it but outside of those two
things like how else can the momentum be
stopped and potentially
reversed well so the challenge the
reason I'm not
optimistic is because they can come up
with new things to screw us faster than
we can debunk and I don't like the word
debunk in general because it assumes
that you already know the answer and
you're going to collect the data to show
the answer and um but but but so so
let's say we win I think I think the the
transgenders in sports is going to die a
natural death because it's so stupid
it's it's insane so so when I write
about it I'm gonna write about two
things first I'm
gonna I've got notes and on all
this first of all I'm going to point out
that if you're a legitimate transgender
you have my sympathy because it's a
tough world and and it's hard enough to
be a teenager you can be the captain of
the football team and you still have
self-doubts because you're 16 or 17
years old 18 years old and and you could
be the hottest Chicken on the planet you
still think your ass is fat um and um
and and so it it's in an age bracket
where self-doubts are just everywhere
and the problem is you have these adults
who themselves are suffering from you
know
transgender by proxy and and and they're
telling you oh your problem is that
you're actually a female and and we can
make you
happy and so it's a sucker bet so so so
so um the two things I'm going to go
against is one is doing medical
interventions on
teenagers um I'm already seeing that
starting to collapse because I think the
um I think the liability insurance for
the medal system is now starting to soar
because the the hospitals that are doing
transgender surgeries and injections and
stuff are starting to get their asses
suit off and I want to see them
destroyed because I don't think you
should ever let a a a pre-adult make
that call and you say well what about
their parents and I go uh you know we
don't let parents tie their kids up in
the basement and beat them either if we
get wind of it Society will step in on
that one
too and so you know and and they said
what if they think think they're you
know they really feel like they're a
woman I go well you know when someone
says you know I'm fat and they're
anorexic we don't let them identify is
fat we say no get them
help and so so this idea that someone
who thinks they're female and and then
you get you know middle schools with 50
transgenders in one Middle School this
is not a medical problem this is a
social movement right and which is fine
it's a little embarrassing when you're
in a fraternity years later and your
friends find out you spent time in dress
and you know 8th grade but um but but
when we're sterilizing them and doing
bad things and and and you know the
horror of Horrors is the fake vaginas I
think those people I'm spending the rest
of their life in extreme Agony is my
understanding they just don't work and
and it's the the adults doing it I think
are are you know when the swedes first
started doing I think it was the
swedes they spent several years
working with the person to make sure
that they really were a good
candidate for some sort of transgender
treatment and and now it's as little as
an hour chat with a shrink and next
thing you know you're getting
injections and maybe these injections
don't hurt you but I've read just too
many articles saying that you know it
sterilizes you and it's not reversible
and you have to keep doing it and and so
there there's just there's just no way
we should be doing this to kids and and
they say well but if you don't do it
young then I go I don't
care I just don't care I I just I I I
think that doing something such an
intervention on on a teenager and I I
think we're going to look up 10 years
from now and there's going to be a bunch
of adults who
transitioned and they're going to be
saying to their parents where were you
when I needed
you you needed to be my parents you
needed to say whoa whoa whoa slow down
go ahead wear a dress to school that's
great go ahead let your hair out you
know braid your hair I don't I don't
care but no we're not going to castrate
you and so so there's that and then
there's the sports you know women in
sports when when Title Nine showed up
there were two noticeable things one is
women started getting opportunities and
sports they can get and and a number of
men's sports were destroyed so I happen
to have been a gymnast in the old days
and most gymnastics teams got wiped out
wrestling programs got wiped out because
they needed to somehow find a way to
equate the two two gender Sports and the
lawyers on the campuses concluded it was
money spent or something and so they
wiped out men's sports to bring them
down and elevator women sports now I've
also coached two collegiate Sports both
gymnastics and
Taekwondo and U both have women's
components and I see what sports do for
women and it's phenomenal it's
phenomenal Taekwondo especially
Taekwondo is way better for the women
than the men it's not because it teaches
them to be killing machines it teaches
you to have composure when someone's
smacking
you and to say look if it doesn't
actually hurt me it it's not a problem
right if if they actually damage me it's
a problem but it's not a problem that
someone's in my personal space I have to
deal with them but you learn that's what
it teach you how to when I used to taond
I was a little older and um I uh I used
to go right into range and use all
defense I'd Spar against the Cornell
kids they were good they're second in
the nation um and I'd go right into
range on smack away and
defend and and and would drive them nuts
actually they go he's in my face
constantly and I would just block and
then I'd wait and then all of a sudden
they'd be they'd kick me six seven times
without scoring a point I'd see an
opening I'd smack them and uh and it
worked pretty well and and women
learning that now now you've got this
thing where women have gotten their
Sports and now you're saying oh now
let's guys compete now let's like guys
compete so I and what I'm stunned by is
the entire female sports establishment
is not standing up and saying
no
no and Riley gains I think she I think
she probably triggered the beginning of
the end she's been doing battle and she
said she had so many
people behind closed doors without
putting their names on it saying I
support you keep up the fight and at one
point the head of the NCA said that she
says I'm fighting
you why would you say that I'm fighting
you I asked a three-time
Olympic medal
winner what her views were and I watched
her tighten
up and I realized I just asked her a
question that almost wasn't fair because
if she answered it honestly and somehow
it got out she'd be kicked off the
team and that shouldn't be
happening but I think we're getting to
the point now where women are bailing
out of sports there was a uh jiujitsu
Championship where tournament there's
tons of these things where where where
something like all the weight class were
won by dudes and I'm going to call them
dudes because I don't give a
um and and and there were actually
divisions that were all
dudes but at some level I think some of
these guys who are the most appalling
cases are actually guys who are trying
to destroy the idea so when the weight
lifter says I'm a d I'm a chick and then
he breaks the world
record he's he's jamming it in their
face so I'm not sure that they're all
bad I think they're doing do doing the
right work so well zubie um is I you
must have been an athlete I can see I
can see it in your face you're chiseled
what what sport you
do uh I played uh football basketball
and baseball in high school right and uh
I mean look there's also um I I don't
think people quite understand the
difference of athleticism even between
um in I think it was College
uh yeah in college um certain Sports
would play other sports in their sport
and without passing judgment you know
there are certain Sports where the
people are bigger faster stronger more
athletic and yes they can use those uh
those components to make up for the lack
of you know finite or kind of nuanced
skill so if you take a football team and
you go and you play soccer right of
course uh the soccer players are better
at all of the skills that are needed for
soccer but if you play for a certain
amount of time there's a good chance
that some of the football players may
actually be able to score quite often
because they're bigger they're biger
faster whatever right one of the most
famous lacrosse players of all time was
Jimmy Brown the running back yes and I
can't he used to put his thumb on the
ball it turns out I I knew the head
coach and and but he can you imagine
being a midfielder and having Jimmy
Brown running at you with the ball you
would just send up a smudge Mark right
so about the
women's uh Olympic hockey team practices
by playing against prep
schools yes boys prep schools yes right
now we've seen this I think um uh Klay
Travis I think I saw he's the guy who
issued like a million-dollar bet he said
I'll pick you know the best men's uh
high school team and they'll go play a
WNBA team or whatever and so like again
that is the extreme you know somewhat
zero sum really trying to make a uh um
kind of a bombastic you know Point by uh
doing this but to your point we actually
can just look at what the teams are
doing themselves and I don't think that
it's a a positive or A negative right I
have a daughter I I don't think that
there's certain sports that I would want
her to play if I knew you know like what
is she gonna go play football right
she's like Hey Dad I'm gonna go sign up
to be the running back I would be like
uh you know let's make some different
choices here right by the way we're not
going to do trans gender surgery on you
either right um now in fact
I'm my son was a pretty good skater when
he was real little and I I sort of waved
him away from hockey because I decided
that the hockey culture was kind of
toxic the parents were toxic um but I
don't think I'd want a kid to play
football as much as I I understand I I
you know the the the the the the head
head wrists are are there that are
serious enough that you know you know
some probably 75% of them now on bitcoin
so you know we know they're
demented when you start thinking about
um 2024 and Beyond there's a lot of
problems in the world right what is what
what's the positive view what what what
passes your filter as to like these are
the things that are going right this
episode is brought to you by cal.com
what do I have in common with Chad
Hurley from YouTube Toby from Shopify
and Alexis from 776 and the co-founder
of Reddit we all use cal.com instead of
cly and we are all early investors as
well cal.com is leading the charge of
scheduling Platforms in the open-source
sphere offering you the chance to
harness the efficiency previously
reserved for League corporations and
Tech gurus if you like to have your
calendar organized and be able to have
an efficient exchange when scheduling
but you love all of the benefits of Open
Source technology than cal.com is for
you they are transforming sophisticated
calendar management into an accessible
tool for all via a userfriendly
interface you can customize it and you
can make your calendar work for you use
code pomp for $500 off when you set up
your team with cal.com today again go to
cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an
open-source tool that allows you to take
back control of your calendar be
efficient when scheduling and make sure
that no one can steal your time
well again kon's very good on this one
too um if you remember back in the 60s
it felt like the world was collapsing
around us you know the Vietnam War was
going on to the older generation they
were watching their kids all of a sudden
they discover free sex with birth
control they discover
drugs rock and roll sounded awful to
them you know Elvis Presley wiggling his
hips and you know so they went from
Bobby Darren and Anette Funicello to to
the doors very quickly and uh and so and
you had the Civil Rights violence in the
in the cities and stuff and so um double
digit inflation soon thereafter so you
know it there's always tough times and
and so you have to remind yourself that
this is not that different again Michael
mice's book reminds you how bad it can
get there's nothing in the United States
nothing in the United States that
approximates what the Soviet Union was
doing to people um anywhere pick the
worst place Camden I don't care there's
nothing um and um and so I have to
remind myself with that um I do think
we're heading into a period of talt so
so you know the Great Depression lasted
what a decade I argue it ask I got an
argument with a Stanford Economist I
think it was
Stanford I said that the the Great
depression didn't end till after World
War
II he said well you know and I talked
about restricted consumption and things
like that and he said yeah well you know
but but it turns out the GDP showed
showed that um the Depression had ended
during the warant and I spent some time
pondering it and I said no no no no no
no because your GDP was a false GDP you
were creating and blowing it up
right so if you create to me gross
domestic product needs depreciation rate
component built into it so if you make a
blender the last 40 years your GDP is
better than if you make that same
blender but it only lasts five years
because of
breaks and that's one of the
missing um so you didn't produce the
wealth making the chintzy blunder that
you did making the good blunder and and
so during the war the depreciation rate
of everything was phenomenal we're
making battleships we getting sunk and
we were making planes we going down and
we're weapons and you know ammo and
it was just very costly and but so I
don't I you can't count that as
GDP and here's a GDP point that you
might have picked up you might not
have tell me that's Robert Gordon's book
um that you suggested this to me two
years ago did you read it's one of the
best books I I've told tons of people
about it for those that don't know the
rise and fall of American growth and it
basically makes the argument that uh was
it 1870 to like 1940 I think is uh the
timeline
um there's tons of uh Innovation there's
tons of GDP growth um my favorite
example well two of them one is the
elevator and the importance of building
Urban density by one simple invention um
running water electricity I was going
say the second one is every home is
completely disconnected you know in 1870
and by 1940 they're all connected uh
roads electricity you know uh phone
lines the whole thing orvo right live
long enough to see
wrap your brain around that right people
talk about Amazon being pioneering
Amazon was not pioneering the Sears robu
catalog was pioneering Sears robu
catalog was Amazon yes it took a couple
weeks not a day and it wasn't anywhere
near as big but we went from guys buying
you know flower out of barrels and
Country Stores all over the country see
ordering having a train deliver it
to you sometime you could order pre web
houses and stuff right there you could
order all the car parts you needed from
the Sears robot catalog and uh and so
that was just Amazon and Amazon's just a
more digital version and uh the other
thing that's really interesting is
there's remember the part about primary
versus secondary invention so
electricity would be
primary and a vacuum cleaner or or a
dishwasher or something would be
secondary the best decade for secondary
inventions was the 1930
s right in the middle of the Great
Depression we invented more secondary
inventions than any decade so we created
wealth during the Great Depression and
uh and um here's where we're going to
get we're going to be lied to in a very
big way and I I hinted this I kind of
talk about it a little bit this year
where as the Boomers get older we're g
to spend a fortune on health care and
that's going to go into GDP when in fact
it is the cost of keeping up a rapidly
depreciating
asset so we're we're it is the cost of
struggling to keep an asset that's
trying to go to dust from going to dust
that's not gross domestic product that's
depreciation but it's going to show up
US
GDP when you think about the national
debt uh we're at 33 trillion on our way
to a
gazillion um we could try to grow our
way out of it that that is a not going
to happen that is a uh it is a option
but I know you don't think it's going to
happen what what would have to change in
order to be able to do it I think we're
already past the fails safe point so I
think we already have the
commitments you know the social programs
and the Social Security and the and the
military we we we'd have to drop our
military to zero and and Kennedy might
do that but um he's not getting in the
the White House um
and um and and what do we grow the debt
grew last year 10% so that's a death
spiral there's not a shred of evidence
that the political system has any sort
of Backbone in it to stop that
spending we spent 200 billion on on
Ukraine what if I were Powell I'd be
livid the guys who say Powell's beholden
to the administration I go po I would
think would want to ring the neck of the
administration is he's trying to get
control of monetary policy and their
fiscal policy is completely out of
control and so um and so I think we're
past that point I think you could you
know there's a town in California that
that had a water problem it's a good
example of a more General principle and
they said we got to cut consumption 20%
there's no question you can cut 20%
consumption of water anywhere there's no
question you can do it at the end of the
year they had cut three
% and and so people don't we don't do it
we will drive the car off a cliff like
Thalman Louise and clean up the pieces
later and so um what I can't picture is
how it
resolves so it will
resolve right it doesn't just stop it's
a it's an infinite Loop right it will
resolve but I I can't picture they say
well we're going to inflate it away and
I
go have you noticed how mad people are
at inflation right now we're just
warming up if that's the model we are
just warm I just I went to get a roast
at the
store
yesterday now I'm not sure what the
roast was they tried to sell me but I I
said yeah I'm looking for a roast a
pretty big one and I point one I said
tell me that one right there how much
would that cost and uh he puts on the
scale and he says
$240 I I go what I said I think we'll
have a boneless turkey instead um and uh
and and you know the inflation rots
societies and it's it's making people
grumpy and there's people going the
store I I you know there remember five
years ago you'd see some article that
would say you know 50% of the population
doesn't have money in the bank to cover
a $400
emergency where are they now
now right they they're they don't have
they don't have a penny they they they
swallow that $400 in in six months that
margin of error so paycheck to paycheck
is not even true anymore now it's
paycheck to credit card to debt to
whatever it's not like you can refy your
house
right so we've milked that that we've
milked that lactating cow down to bone
dry one of the um most interesting stats
uh and I wrote about it the other day is
I basically said the financial markets
are like uh the crouched lion right they
they kind of Sprint from far away land
get close to the prey Crouch down inch
closer and by the time the prey realizes
they're there it's over um and it feels
like financial markets have been doing
that but probably the best example is
single family homes in America have been
going up even though interest rates are
over 5% and mortgage you know 30-year uh
fix went over 8% and it's on a national
level at least exactly the opposite of
what everyone told you was going to
happen well I think though I think it's
a broken Market though so there is no
price to so so there's a they call it a
tight housing market but it's only tight
because those who want to sell and those
who want to buy can't can't see eye to
eye so there's no price Discovery and so
the people who have the 3%
mortgage simply won't sell because they
don't want to then end up with a 7%
mortgage and and so so but at some point
people have to sell it Boomers again
rapidly depreciating asset they're
rapidly depreciating houses are going to
be sold by rapidly depreciating Boomers
and and who's who's going to buy those
mcmansions not Barry sternik and and and
I did a pretty good job I think this
year of laying out the the the the rise
of the the permanent Capital purchasing
of houses and how they they made a
business model out of buying single
family homes which is a terrible
business to rent single family homes by
getting them on fire sale in 0809 by by
hiking rents like crazy by getting the
capital to leverage the out of it
it you know I I read somewhere that that
that black stone or Black Rock I can
never keep those two separate um was
getting money at
0.15% so you take a terrible business
you lever the out of it you make a
Raaz within profit margin on a hugely
levered
portfolio and then well what would hurt
this business model well rates
rising and rates have risen so I I
figure that we are about to see
explosions all over the real estate
market why they are not yet Audible
is unclear to me but they have to
because the cost of buying a house just
doubled and so you either have to buy
half the house or pay half as much or
something but it just doubled and you
know what it's like to buy a house you
sit down with the realtor they say how
much money do you have how what's your
annual income this is how much you can
afford and your wife says that's what
we're
buying and and and so so if the the
realter
says that quantity of is what you can
afford divided by two
now because everything costs more then
then who's you know uh round numbers the
real estate market has to cut in half
will they ever let that happen or will
they step in yeah yeah no they have to
let it happen no because then we'll have
an inflation problem remember how
Twitter used to be loaded with people
saying oh I'd love inflation because
that'll make my mortgage cheaper how's
that working out for you guys is your
mortgage any cheaper the answer is no
because you're because your wages are as
sticky as your goddamn mortgage so I had
a guy Joe mccan um he's a former macr
Trader worked at a place that you would
know um he's got a partner who worked
for a very well-known billionaire
investor uh managed you know hundreds of
millions of dollars if not billions each
individually they now run a fund um
that's focused on the crypto market and
one of the things that he said to me is
he his friend said to him and now it's
kind of become his calling card that
essentially the government in the FED is
in a precarious position it's either
full-blown depression or dog coins to a
trillion that's you know that that's
kind of their uh their optionality and
so a full-blown depression actually
sounds way worse than dogcoin but cryp
crypto is highly
inflationary correct the introduction of
crypto that's says a lot it's not if you
own it right it's an inflation hedge if
you own it but it's highly inflationary
to the system because what's it worth
that two trillion is that a round number
good guess something like that yeah call
it two trillion that's two trillion that
didn't
exist that came from zero right that
came from scratch now there's some
upfront cost buying servers and stuff
like that I remember when guys were
mining crypto on their
telephones right that was how easy it
was in the olden days when when only
nutballs like Max Kaiser were buying it
um but um yeah I turned it down at 10
10 bucks coin um and I think there's a
there's a difference between like
Bitcoin being kind of you know digital
gold whatever um and I think you know
macro investors say like okay cool if I
see gold this is a digital version like
I can wrap my head around that what he
was really talking about was like the
craziness the absolute insan Insanity of
Dogecoin going up to you know $50
billion or whatever right and it was
kind of this you know uh but that
doesn't that doesn't create the wealth
right that's that in itself is a
fictional it's just a it's not wealth
creation it's wealth aggregation it's
just shifting wealth yeah and and it's
at some point you have to create wealth
it's at some point the entire system is
based on wealth creation AKA Robert
Gordon's book not just you know Nvidia
is going to be on a on a milk carton at
some point right Nvidia Nvidia is priced
five times what sun microsystem is
priced at before did a 95 Swan Di and
video is going to be laughable it's
going to be hysterical it's going to be
it's going to be a chapter of you know
what not to do
books so you think Nvidia is going to be
one of the poster children for great
crash
yeah right there a lot of people who
disagree with you I know that's why it's
so
pricey right at the
top let's let's say the market so so as
you know I make a case for a 40-year
secular bare
Market a four de multi-decade bare
market now not to say it won't go up and
down people will be able to trade it but
if you think well that could never
happen I go don't tell the Japanese
they're still underwater 35 years later
and and another detail of the Japanese
Market is let's say if you own the
Nik you owned 14 of the 20 biggest
companies in the
world how could that go wrong right how
could that possibly go wrong well the
guys who own the US market now own the
mag
7 and um and even Buffett turned on sort
of us equities this year he he kind of
said H you know 40 some number of years
from now the US will not have the
biggest companies and so um I thought he
said don't never bet against America
what is he changing his mind yeah yes he
appears to have changed his mind because
he's looking at the craziness um if you
instead of owning the N you just started
buying it you're some 22y old Japanese
kid who just got out of University of
Tokyo and you started averaging down
took you 20 years to break even 20 years
to break even now you're doing okay now
but but when the the Boomers have to
sell their
equities and they're talking about this
big wealth transfer from Boomers to
their kids I
their kids have to buy the
stocks that the kids are supposed to get
rich
on the Boomers have to sell them to
someone and and therefore you know it's
it's it's not going to be a wealth
transfer without without a depreciation
of the ticker
price because there's no one to buy
it and and and so I I think we are going
to have I I talk about about about 10 10
Tailwinds that we had from 1981 to the
present and then I kind of cover how
those will now be
headwinds and it's not to say it'll
happen today or tomorrow or next year or
even this
decade but I'm confident that somewhere
over the next 40 years you're going to
look up and say you know we haven't
moved
anywhere because we're sitting at 150%
overvalued and if you're 150% overvalued
and you tread water inflation adjust you
just tread water and say okay I'll just
buy and hold and wait and let let the
market come back to fair value slowly 35
years 35 years of Treading Water you
want to go straight down it's like 68%
or something you wanna you wanna you wan
to you w to stretch it out over 50 years
you can get a total gain of about 20%
compounded that's like
0.5% over 50
years once you are up
at these nose bleed levels there's no
safe root home
period golden cash that's it well and
then you've got to somehow beat
inflation so we're in treacherous Waters
someone will do well and they will be
deified as the investor of the
decade and it might be a hler might be a
goler might be uh might be some guy who
found a couple of small companies that
are just going to
rock my worst investment ever was I I I
I received shares of Lab Corp of
America in a in a merger that eventually
I didn't know what they were I knew what
I own but I didn't know what they were
and so I sold them and they're up
hundredfold that was the worst move I
ever made was selling Lab Corp of
America so but I've done well I'm I'm if
I can tie
inflation I'll do fine I'm in good shape
all right I've got two last questions
for you before I let you go one name
three investors that you're impressed
with right now that people may not know
who are the people that you pay
attention to what they're talking about
uh what they're doing um when you've got
a question or an idea you you call and
talk to them who who are uh uh three
people that just may surprise
folks well I don't know if they can
surprise
because
um a guy I get a lot of useful
information from is Jesse
Felder um I get a lot of useful
information off a guy who just appeared
on my radar about a year ago is but it's
not about investing it's more about
macro is is Peter St an he's on Twitter
if you're not following him you should
Peterson is Prof St an n
g and uh brilliant macroanalysis snarky
as does one a day very entertaining
Rising
Star
um and
uh who do I think really as a I I you
know I have money with a couple guys a
small cap investor who I like a lot is
Eric cinnamon I like the guys at Horizon
Kinetics I haven't given them money yet
because I think there's going to be some
serious
whooshing the mistake I'll tell you what
the mistake I made in ' 089 was so so
liquid um
I was so convinced you know Einhorn I
think at least he says he invented the
phrase but if what's a 90% correction
well it's an 80% correction that thing
Cuts in
half and and so so if if if you buy
because it's Dirt Cheap because it's
dropped 50 and then it drops to 75 you
just lost half your
money now better than buying it at the
top but this I started to talk about
what's the top the top is is some
Tuesday afternoon at
23 the Nik hit its
peak and the peak represents period of
Maximum optimism as evidenced by the
price and the precise moment when the
justification for optimism is zero
0.0 you're about to go in through the
valy of death for the next 35 years and
um and no one knows it so it's like
Father Guido Sarducci's coming in a
going Planet you remember you know that
do you remember that skit from SNL where
he's talking about he's talking about uh
how you get older and then you get
younger and he says and you meet this
young chick he's speaking in his Italian
accent and and he says he says you're 20
and she's a she's a 18 and she's really
hot next thing you know you're 22 and
she's a 16 and he says now you're in a
biger trouble and and in some sense the
markets are like that you know where
you're at but you which direction
they're
going now I'm confident that um the
markets have big
downside as expressed by either serious
price drop or seriously long period of
just suck ass and to me time is my enemy
not price I would love to have a massive
correction I'd love to have a three-year
drop into the Great Depression um what I
don't want to do is what would suck
would be be our last really correct
serious correction was 1967 to 81 we
lost 75% inflation adjusted and it took
14 years losing 75% is a giving up
14 years of your investing life a third
of your investing life
really to get nothing to to lose that
75% that kills you that's what killed
the the N investors time time time as
your enemy so times your friend in a bar
bull market and times your enemy in a
bare Market I'm predicting a
multi-decade bare Market where time will
be your worst enemy and I don't know I
think the markets could be uninvestable
I I did a spaces with George Noble what
an honor um and I said I thought the
markets would be uninvestable he asked
me to explain I said The N he says well
you could short I said no you couldn't
took too long you'd burn your money to a
Cris trying to short the N because it
didn't just drop like a stone it just
worked its way down over about 15 years
you go broke trying to short that thing
so I think the markets could become
absolutely uninvestable besides the
occasional lucky person who can cherry
pick but that that's said the seem to
lab you know Fool by Randomness moment
right that's where there are going to be
in in a sample size of 10,000 money
managers there's going to be some who
flip the coin heads 10 times in a row
it's
statistical so there will be winners are
they because they're geniuses I got to
figure dren Miller had a special touch I
think David terer has a special touch
diio who I think is a
hoser but I read his
book and and it was very good it was
kind of forth turning with a greater
military and economic component but he
sees us going into a period of great uh
stress and violence he's he were right
on the cusp of a of a you know 15 20
year cycle
and so my last qu my last question is uh
you put the books that you read each
year at the end of the letters um so
people can go check those out but uh if
you had to pick one or two books
throughout your life that really stand
out as having the biggest impact on the
way you think the way you see financial
markets uh or even think about some of
the other topics we've talked about what
are like the one or two books that you
would
suggest
um that's kind of an obscure one called
banking in the business cycle written in
1937 I actually read the original but
then they reprinted it so you can buy it
probably on Amazon by Phillips and
mcmanis I think and it was about what
really created the Great
Depression and it was an Austrian view
um the price of time is a modern book
that everyone should read um and if you
know Edward Chancellor is considered God
in this world of you know credit and and
crisis and and and he says that when
interest rates get to 2% you always have
a crisis well they went negative so you
know I think Edward's probably uh
watching the tickers with interest uh
the the great crash of 1929's a classic
um um I think I I really like Robert
Gordon's book which we talked about I
really like the great believer the True
Believer which we talked about
um sleep right there the the mystery of
capital by Hernando doodo is about
International markets and international
economics and why Africa's never going
to be a a hub of financial of wealth
creation
um um I'm trying to think what else I
should put together this list I have at
least a dozen years of it of
books um my big advice is audiobooks
when your wife sends you to the store
she's actually asking you to read for 10
minutes each way when I commute 12
minutes to work it's 24 minutes of
reading um I can get through about 25
books a year just in the car and uh and
so uh and you can always get through the
book and and uh I encourage people to
read
history I read about the Middle Ages
Middle Ages are great by the way ah
World lit only by fire great book very
snarky very funny yeah but I've read
about Roman history and I've read
probably half dozen books in the Middle
East um nothing
stuck um avoid books that
um too many names too many foreign names
I started to read Gordon Chang's book
about China and there was just too many
Chinese
guys um
whereas Michael Mouse's book about
Russia is not so he avoided that trap
somehow and so I'm a big I'm I'm partway
through it right now but it's
unbelievable
book uh how about you you tell me add
some um I would say books over the
last I don't know year or so um that I
would really suggest I got a whole list
here of uh one give us give us no coin
or the book if you had one book you said
look I got one one
pitch what's the pitch I'm gonna read
Lyn Al's book yeah in terms of like uh
just a book to read about crypto stuff
uh or Bitcoin um there must be oneok
money it's either money that's my that's
my next book actually or uh safine uh
the Bitcoin standard I would say those
two are the the uh the books my buddy
Jason Williams he wrote one uh called
hard money you can't f with um that's
pretty good too that's I like those
three um let's see books uh this year uh
Barton bigs
hedgehogging you everever read that one
I think I I think I read that one that's
got that's about 15 years old I think
that almost got some age on it yeah the
uh the Raven of zerk is a good one um I
really like this uh it's called rules
for aging Roger rosenblat it's kind of
like a you know um piy things that you
can do in your life to here's one for
you Millionaire Next Door was very good
oh yeah that is a good one I I once
stood listen to a guy who I might call
kind of a a digital friend I don't know
what you call him where he gave a talk
on 10 stupid books and that was one of
them and I afterwards I said you didn't
read it did you there's no way you read
that book he just thought it sounded
stupid and um it's about saving it's
about the psychology of saving so I I I
think if you don't understand that what
it's really about a SA saving not about
not about investing it's about saving so
so you may have noticed I had an
expensive year I bought my wife a car
and I had to do some around the
house and I still saved 25% of my gross
salary right so so when my kids were in
college I still had a net savings when
my kids were in college and uh and that
that is the one time I said to my dad I
think I should be saving more he started
to rip into me I said 'well I no I'm
saving between 25 and 30% of my gross he
said' oh never mind right he backed off
he thought I was not saving anything I
said no but I had have I'd to be able to
do better if I was living on a low
salary got some big raises should have
been able to live should have been able
to save a huge percentage of that but
your your your life expands to fill your
wealth right you somehow find a way so
if you can save 25% of your
gross the rest is noise at some
level I uh I could not agree more where
can we send people to find you on the
internet if they want more Dave colum
well I do try to answer emails they're
getting this time of year it's it's a
bit of a nightmare um but I try to
answer them um and um that's how I met a
lot of people I I called called an email
like to Rickards or something like that
and and and they'd answer back a you
know some very famous guy I just had an
email exchange with Jeff
Sachs and he says thank God we're not
University presidents right I'm going no
kidding um and then I'm at uh um I'm at
Twitter at David B column where my pin
tweet is my year and review I appreciate
your time everyone looks forward to this
every year and we will do it again in
2024 my friend adios